he talked about switching up cognitive
processes are there certain movies that
seem to do that throughout the two-hour
span that you're really going from one
emotion to the next back-and-forth sure
there are lots of movies that
fast-forward your emotions most of your
Jack Reacher kind of you know solve the
crime stay out of danger are moving at a
very quick pace those movies tend not to
involve much humor or much regret those
movies tend to be based on fear and
anticipation so they keep kind of a
higher heart rate going while you're
watching the movies that are more
psychological or involved the aspect of
reflection thinking about your memories
so I got them 500 days or 50 first dates
those kinds of movies that display
people portray people that have lost
memory or not forming memories properly
are very engaging real successful in the
box-office more engaging for an audience
who may not be you know a hero or a
daredevil or that kind of a person maybe
can watch those but have a lingering
appreciation for someone whose mind is
not working exactly the way theirs is so
lots of movies come at different
cognitive processes and in forming a
story around not working cognitive
processes some kind of brain injury that
has changed that person you get a lot of
fascination from the viewers perspective
because everybody relates to forgetting
at some time or another everybody's had
a forgetful experience what is it like
to not be able to form a memory so that
you live
in forgotten state those are some
interesting psychological brain
processes that have been presented and
done well in the theaters one of the
aspects that we point out in science of
screenwriting is how skilled
screenwriters build in the contrast of
emotions so there's been some studies
done and researchers have used eye
trackers in audiences such that they can
tell where the audience's eyes are
focused on the screen during which kinds
of movies and because we can measure
things like how long the eyes stay on
the character and how often the eyes
move off the character we can translate
those eye movements into attentional
factors and we now understand that
timing is critical so an viewer can take
about three minutes of tension of that
kind of bond fighting with the shark or
whatever that is and then there needs to
be a break or the eyes are gonna saccade
you can't take too much tension so we
need a relief so if you'll notice in the
Bond movies it's really brief it's about
a minute and a half where it's death
murder kill kind of you know tension and
then there's a segue whether that means
that there's a further away shot a long
distance shot or a scan to the boat
that's coming to the rescue or whatever
interruption in order to give the nerves
the the brain processes that are
building tension in that watcher a break
and it it has to be at least you know at
90 second breaks of the scan away before
you can re-engage in a tight emotional
situation so we know those processes are
happening in daily life and that when
people go to a movie they and anticipate
experiencing deeper tension more
dramatic exchanges but in order to
maintain their attention you still have
to give those interactive breaks so that
there's a release and then a reagent in
the tension and conflict
you